[Music]
whoever predicted that the world of
politics would get
less absurd once donald trump left
office didn't count on having a
conspiracy theorist who blamed wildfires
on a jewish space laser and a second
amendment-loving gun-themed restaurant
owner who doesn't realize
that amending the constitution means
you've changed it duking it out for
republican freshman of the year in the
house
that's not a good thing they didn't
count on mitch mcconnell learning the
hard way that what citizens united
creates it
well it can also take away mcconnell has
been very explicit in saying that
corporations are people
only when they're writing big checks to
republicans no really that's what he
said
if i were running a major corporation
i'd stay out of politics
i'm not talking about political
contributions
shut up and give me all your money
mcconnell tried to clarify today by
pretty much repeating what he said
and insulting corporations so that's
going well for him and the gop
and the 2021 will be more boring folks
also didn't count on congressman matt
gates
any part of matt gates the florida
congressman as we discussed earlier
is the subject of a federal
investigation over violating sex
trafficking law something he denies
and yet now we've learned that he's set
to be the keynote speaker
at wait for it a women for america
conference
that's a conservative women's group in
case you were wondering oh and yes the
venue for matt gates to mansplain
whatever
to a room full of women is a trump golf
club
because of course it is how could gate's
speech be held anywhere else
perhaps it wasn't just a trump
presidency that looked like an episode
of veep
perhaps it's right-wing american
politics as a whole these days
joining me now is the perfect person to
talk about this with david mandel the
executive producer of veep
uh david thanks so much for coming back
on the show it's been a while
let me ask you this what was your
prediction for the absurdity quotient
of 2021 political news once trump left
office did you think
we'll get back to normal in 2021 under
joe biden or did you expect it to carry
on
being this crazy i i was definitely
expecting
more normal i was honestly and i do feel
like we had like a month off they kind
of gave us a month
and then uh it's it's just back it's
back to the crazy
um i also just want to take a moment to
formally endorse
whoever on the planet earth runs against
mo brooks they have my endorsement
i just want to uh i watched your last
segment and uh
whoever does quote minecomp has my
endorsement i i mean again
i've said this before and i'll say it
again it's a very high bar to me isn't
it david
it's a very high bar if you don't quote
me go for the senate in alabama
that's my only piece of advice don't
quote mine comp oh i accidentally quoted
minecomp i mean it just
yeah yeah can't write it indeed get
right
tell us about your new show david tell
us about your new show the white house
plumbers
starring woody harrelson as e howard
hunt and justin through as
g gordon liddy who died last week of
course what is that all about remind us
um it's basically it's a mini-series uh
for hbo
that's basically going to kind of look
at watergate
uh through the perspective of the
plumbers who you know did the break in
hunt and liddy
and really in some ways it's sort of in
those
early days of the the dare i say the
conservative movement it's it's the
birth of the true believers the true
believers that almost kind of
you know just are willing to sort of
almost burn the whole thing down
in the name of this you know this sort
of ins
to me insane uh just uh advocacy of what
they think is right and why you're wrong
um whether you know again that's i think
what's interesting about it and we're
just
we're just sort of starting on the
pre-production we're going to hopefully
start shooting in may so we're kind of
just rolling into it right now
can't wait to see it you're directing it
obviously as you say you're just
starting production you've immersed
yourself i'm assuming
in that nixonian world a lot of people
have compared nixon and trump
who's more crooked who's more corrupt in
your view
um in my view and i and i truly believe
in history
when history kind of you know as we get
a little further and we we
we write about it you know there's that
moment where even nixon realized he had
to resign
um that that just doesn't exist for
trump the the level of
personal corruption the family the money
his the children the the the pardons
just all of those things the just the
the hotel business you know what i mean
it's just
like at no point did nixon ever open a
restaurant in dc
and make people go to it you know what i
mean it's just a whole other level
that i'm pretty sure the framer is never
counted on
it's just a very different thing um that
uh i again i do think we need a little
distance but
the the further we get the worse it will
seem is what i honestly believe about
these trump years sorry
i was just going to say but i do think
what's really interesting is looking
back on nixon and again that we're going
to do a little this in in in our thing
is it it it it it doesn't
trump becomes less shocking this has
been a slow
journey to trump he didn't come out of
nowhere
this has been going on i guess as far as
i'm concerned
since lyndon johnson signed the civil
rights act
that's that's the honest answer there is
a uh
just a hard line of racism that just
colors all of this and gets us to trump
and i'm sorry to say the modern
republican party and uh
i i do really feel that way and by
looking backwards
you you start to understand what's going
on right now
a couple of things that come to mind as
you were just speaking there i mean we
talked about mo
brooks in in in the earlier segment and
we talked about donald trump we talked
about marjory taylor green i mean
richard nixon for all his many flaws
sins and crimes
was a smart guy was an intelligent
person
no one ever questioned his intellect or
his grasp of politics these people are
on a different level
level of kind of ignorance and
conspiracism and the other point you
made is such a good point that nixon
agreed to get at the end to give it up
whereas trump is still putting out
statements saying the election was
stolen but yeah easter statements
which are all about how the election was
stolen from by the way happy easter
which reminds us just how off the you
know how in a different planet donald
trump is
yeah and let's also point out that he is
putting out statements
i mean all along he's been putting out
statements
about how either now obviously it's they
stole the election but before the
election that they were going to steal
the election
and in those earlier statements about
how the democrats were going to steal
the election
they were taking people's credit card
numbers bank account information
and emptying their their own orders
accounts of
money in the name of stop we're going to
steal from you
and not tell you while we're accusing
other people of stealing and that that's
the
the grand grift of this entire thing
that
just throws it into this other on nixon
level
yeah and again it just uh these are
these are ideas that would have gotten
me thrown out of the viper's room
that's that's again i keep coming back
to that in a very funny way well
it's something it's something you and i
talked to i remember when you came on
the show last time this idea that just
you would not you you know you came up
with the gate storyline the trump
this new york times stolen about trump
stealing money from voters uh you know
we'd be you know you'd be laughed out of
our writing rooms you and julia
louis-dreyfus tried to play up the
veepness of trump
at the democratic national convention
last summer which julia
uh hosted the biden team shut you down
didn't they according to a new book
by jonathan allen and amy partners they
didn't like that didn't like the
direction you were going and made you
soften it
um you know again uh they uh
i guess they you know obviously they
were somewhat concerned and again this
is i think something that you know
happens with democrats
alike a lot and you were talking about
this earlier um
with uh you know you're talking about
like al franken and stuff where
we hold ourselves to a higher standard
and this i think their concept was
if we bring if we attack donald trump
for his general mental unfitness that
they're somehow
going to then turn around and do it to
joe biden but that if we don't do it
they won't and of course they do it no
matter what
and my point at the time was exactly
let's just do it
first let's just do it first what are we
waiting for
um and obviously you know it seems in
some ways like during the entire
um uh democrat convention certainly
during his you know
every time joe biden speaks there's this
unfortunate sort of i think sometimes
like i guess republican expectation of
wait till he messes up
let's watch to see how biden messes up
and he doesn't mess up and yet they
never
see what their own guide does as he
whether it's messes up calls people the
wrong name throws toilet paper looks at
an eclipse you know pick
pick your poison but it's you know again
they just attack attack attack
and what i loved about julia hosting the
night of the democratic convention was
we're going to attack back that's why
you hired julie louis-dreyfus
to host the night of your uh convention
to attack back a little bit so
um that that's that was my point it's a
very good point
last quick question before we run out of
time 30 seconds left joe biden
snl is now on its third biden
impersonator that we've counted
is there something about biden that's
hard to satirize is boring biden good
for the country even if it's bad for
comedy and satire
i mean i love boring biden i i do love
it and with no offense to snl all i can
say is check out dana carvey's biden
impression it's really really really
good it's not on
snl but it is really good
and it shows the way to what that
impression
should be could be um it's it's really
quite good yeah
no i've seen it and i i would second
that david mandel will have to leave it
there thank you so much for joining me
tonight i appreciate it
hi i'm mehdi hassan thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe below
to stay up to date
on the day's biggest stories thank you
for watching